now perhaps the best place to start is
the state of the economy economic growth
and the picture there is
well very different to last time around
in the last budget so march 2020 this
is what the office budget responsibility
expected relatively steady growth in the
coming years just look at how different
these latest figures are an enormous
fall in 2020 9.9
and then strong growth this year and
next in fact
7.3 that is the strongest single year
for growth since 1941
and then relatively weak in the medium
term and it's a similar roller coaster
when you look
at borrowing the deficits the amount of
money the government is borrowing last
time around
again the expectation was it's going to
be relatively steady around this 60
billion level
and just look at what is actually now
expected an enormous
tower of borrowing in this year followed
by
relatively smaller deficits but it's
worth just asking the question
how did they get down the short answer
is more
taxes and the result of that is that the
tax burden so taxes as a percentage of
national income
is going to get up to the highest level
since the 1960s 35
of gdp so i asked the chancellor whether
that was something
he was a bit concerned about well ed i
guess what the
chart your chart doesn't show is uh all
the other chancellors if any of them
have had
pandemics to deal with and you know we
haven't had a pandemic like this in over
100 years
and so i think that's remember that's
why we're having this conversation
that's the problem that we're grappling
with and
unsurprisingly you know when you've had
a shock like that
and then when you've had a response the
one and the likes of which we've done i
think any of those other chancellors
probably have ever had to do as much
fiscal support for
the country as i have had to i think
it's reasonable to expect that what we
have to do in response to all of those
things is going to be a bit different
to what's happened in the past that was
the chancellor richie's soon like it's
worth just saying if you look at this
chart you can see a bit of a dink here
the tax burden going down
and then coming up what's happening
there well if you look
at the actual total policies that have
come out of this budget you get a
sense of that this shows you money
leaving the treasury so that's money
coming out of the treasury
and money coming back in you can see
you've got three years
of a lot of money going out followed by
three years
where money comes back in taxes are
increased and if we actually take all of
these bars and just net them off against
each other they more or less cancel
each other out have a look at this this
shows you everything we're talking about
in this budget the total amount
money going out over the course of the
next five years you can see the super
deduction there a lot of money
going into the pockets of businesses but
a big investment there these are all
covered policies all of these gray white
bits and
the white bit in particular that's
self-employment the biggest of them is
actually self-employment policies you've
got other there
and this is money coming back in so
going into the exchequer
fiscal drag those tax allowances being
frozen a lot of people ending up
paying more tax and corporation taxed an
enormous amount almost
four almost 50 billion uh being
increased in corporation tax
going back into the exchequer so a lot
of people wondering was this going to be
a budget where money was going to go in
or out of the treasury it turns out
it's a bit of both